and you
reasonably rested
i think you had nightmares he screamed a
few times really
don't worry i'm accustomed to that sort
of thing
when mitch and scorpion came back from
the war they tossed and turned night
after night
for months this went on
whatever it is
it'll pass yeah
let's hope so
come up with anything
for home and i mean
as a matter of fact
i did
look here
okay tell me
we're the wrench the cutter is the av
and the screwdriver is where the av
should bury its nose cone in the dust
now you must be wondering how we get the
av to do that that old hmg of yours
my gun will be useful elsewhere this
caliber would barely dent the armor of a
heavy hitter like that
there are other ways
here the clamps are solution a satwaf
power station
why down the av there at that exact spot
because once it's on the ground we'll
have to locate it and grab your target
as fast as we can
and the terrain there is typical
california desert flat dry and empty
there'll be a big old sitting duck
hold up one more time wrench is our car
right
the cutter is the av
the screwdriver is where the av should
hit the ground
and the clamp is the satwave power
station that is the net we use to bring
the av down
um
sat wave power station yes
we need to break into it so far so good
but then what and then we strike
we hit the av with an emp of course we
do as soon as the av is in range we
cause an electromagnetic pulse
the onboard electronics should fail out
outright
meaning what engines will shut down
everything will shut down engines
included
drive navigation communication systems
remember need helmet alive unharmed
gotta try not to blow the av to bits
okay i know but i'd say your man had
best be buckled in
this idea if it works you'll be in for a
rough landing
all right let's ride great pop in it's
cold out here
who owns his power station
go over corp
is there any difference who do you think
pulls the government's strings
hey i'm just wondering whose toes were
about to step all over
lee look around it is simple everything
you see is owned by a corporation
and now for something completely
different weirdest thing you've ever
transported go
what are we playing 20 questions come on
answer
the deputy finance director of cow cause
that's chauffeury not smuggling
he wrote in the trunk
flatlined
really dead
a long story maybe someday i'll tell
you you like to mess with the corpse huh
whatever gave you that idea
well wait
scratch that
rogue nash the wrath
you just like to mess with everyone
well then i suppose it's a good thing
i'm on your side isn't it
we've almost reached the dam we'll make
a quick stop here
we need to calibrate you with a turret
i want you to be able to use the gun too
and shut up our chances in general
connect here
do we really have to waste our time on
this
we do
unless you've already used one of these
without help while moving while taking
fire from all directions and still
manage to hit something but somehow i
don't believe that's the case
so don't argue just connect
how should i connect personal link how
else just watch the jack sometimes you
have to jig a little bit
wired in
wait a moment diagnostics first
[__] it keeps giving me an error
odd
let me work around it
and now pan am here's johnny out in the
middle of bum [__] nowhere
great work hey yeah i think your implant
has a virus
the one in the nape of your neck
uh i've got a bioprocessor in my head
that
operates independently of me
probably why your diagnostics flagged it
mm-hmm
okay but no data will leak out of it
through the personal link
your ride's secure fine
i trust you won't [__] anything up
okay
here goes nothing
see that pile of junk fire a short burst
into it i'll take care of the
calibration
good
next target single shot
hey if you'd rather daydream please wait
until we're done calibrating
[Music]
okay
just one more
longer round
great
we're done i think and that wasn't so
bad was it
calibration's fine but your soft could
really use an update
scanner controllers all a couple of
generations back at least
there's better tech in the bargain bin
at a kabuki flea market
i can help you with that you know yes
sure the most important thing is that it
works now
so where's this power station
you will see in a moment
i know a spot we'll have a decent view
from there i just want to be sure the
area is clear
sabotage your corco power station jump a
corporate transport kidnap a corporate
suit there's a plug for the word
corporal or do you have a point know
what you're starting to remind me of me
50 years back
minus the charisma
an impressive [__]
hmm
maybe we can just get along
could be something to that i suppose
what happened to us it must have had
some effect you're more like me than you
think
you'll see but it goes both ways
maybe you're becoming more like me nah
no way
all looks clear the area looks deserted
i see no patrols
the huge thing is the collection unit
and see the antennas
each antenna collects microwave energy
from satellites in orbit
that's then converted into electric
power
power stations serve the whole city
who the [__] knows guess we're about to
find out
huh antennas run all the way down the
interstate
and they're linked which is to your
advantage
we just need to mess with the collection
unit a chain reaction will follow
each one of the antennas will emit an
emp burst
the av will be like a fly headed for a
spider's web we just have to fire off
the pulse at the right moment let's go
get her
once we reach the station i'll set up a
bypass for the detonator you just
overload the systems
pan am what if we cut all the cute stuff
and blow the station up
normally i'd love to but an explosion
would trigger an automatic shutdown
protocol in each collector
all night city would know we were there
well before we got around the protocol
nice idea though
maybe next time
overload the system yes ma'am when do i
start
though
hoping that's not too complicated is it
it shouldn't be you just turn everything
up as far as it'll go crank it up to 11.
got it
so what now
we wait we should time our arrival to
the av flight plan got it
good time to roll
done anything like this before
downing an av
by myself
no
why do you ask
seems rogue was right
the
what she said you were good and she was
right
yes i suppose she was
but we have yet to take the av
so you might wait before you fasten a
halo on her
know what
i think i've figured you out oh you have
that either pull out this mission or
prove rogue wrong choose one [__] off i
will get both done
[Music]
okay we'll be there in a moment
one last time
we drive in [__] up the system and get
the hell out of there
hold on tight this could get a little
bumpy
get ready
okay i'm ready
[Music]
we hurry
find the controls
ah [__]
come on
[__] i think we might have overdone it
pan am
yeah
let's get out of here before it lights
us up too
they get the [__] out before something
happens to the champions of the tip you
know i was just about to set up a picnic
maybe the layout
[Music]
watch out the next one
johnny
[__] hell
okay
i'm fine
it's
it's okay just
it's okay i'm fine yeah
just
dealt to the [__] out
not the cleanest job perhaps but it
still went well what about the detonator
is it working
yes it's working and i don't even see a
drop in the signal strength
we just need to drive far away enough to
keep the pulse from blasting us too
the cliff there
we'll set up
it should give us a good view of the
antennas
and then we wait
okay
here
always wanted to push the big red button
on something like this
how do we know when
don't worry i'll have eyes on it
you just wait for my signal then set off
that pulse
they won't know what hit them
and by the way what
we are about to knock a multi-million
euro dollar kang tao asset clean out of
the sky
how does that make you feel
we only got one chance pan am let's not
screw it up fear not i finish what i
start always
just noticed
what it's quiet
the home of the city people's voices the
smells
it's all gone
wind just intensifies it
think i forgot quiet exists
though maybe not the smells i mean the
coyotes
rather hard to miss thought that was
just the air freshener in your thornton
ha ha
screw you
you'd do better to focus on the av
keep your eyes open
it's there coming from pacifica all
right get ready
one more second
one more
now
boom
there she is
[__] what's going on god damn it all
[__]
[Music]
the engines are still running [__]
they're getting away they're going
nowhere we gotta go after it give me a
moment
pan am what are you doing
that's how you do it it's losing
altitude
we got the bastard let's go
we got it no way it stays in the air
after a blast like that
[Music]
they can't hear me the pulse is
interfering
on radar
yes let's get ready
they're trying to slow us down
we won't let them we have to reach mr
scorpio
[Music]
i know
it's nothing
i'm fine
okay
that's the time being at least time
being
[Music]
so
saw it behind that hill
think you can manage
sure
i'll live
don't worry
hey man where are you
hello perfect keep broadcasting over an
open channel just in case they missed
you the first time god swear
something's not right did you hear those
shots
face something happened to them let's
check it out
i see the wreck but no scorpion or mitch
looks expired
[Music]
v connect to the drone we'll scan the
area we have to get our bearings
they won't mark us
i'll enable the masking their scanners
are out they're blind
let's roll you connecting to visual
mm-hmm
v
if they cut the alticalis if they got
mitch and scorpion i can't
i don't know i know
connected i'm in control
combat drones
defense system is active
they secured the area they're waiting
for reinforcements
[__]
mitch he's alive
they have them
combat drones
defense system is active they secured
the area
they're waiting for reinforcements
[__]
v this does not look good
they set up the lodge they'll tear us to
shreds if we get too close can we take
it down somehow
maybe
but we have to get there first
got five kangs on patrol
foreign
[Music]
oh no no no
i'm
i'm sorry
your clan all to call this
yes
they're dead
all of them
v
if not for those damned glitches i could
have warned them
this is all my doing
why in the hell were they following the
av
the fools
listen we saw mitch they probably got
scorpion too we'll find them help them
out if they're still alive they're alive
everything's gonna be okay
mind that launcher it will blow us to
bits if we approach
okay here's the plan you stay in the car
no not so fast i will go with you
those are my people pan am i hate to
break it to you but you're hurt
wait in the car i'll try and take out
the launcher i
fine
but i have mitch's rifle
and we'll try to cover you from here
good idea
let's move
time for the festivities
you are instructed to reveal
suspect
you are instructed to retire
you are instructed to reveal yourself
locating suspect
you are instructed to repeal
[Music]
so
let's get them
[Music]
utilizing measures
let's get them
oh [__] not good
uh
you are instructed to reveal yourself
[Music]
uh
subject to cooperate
[Music]
that's clear
i'm coming for you
now
step back
back
toss your weapons or i'll shoot
i repeat drop your weapons now
easy now
not too late for everyone to walk out of
this alignment
[__] last chance
you don't got to die today
let's talk should i believe you pan am
sure
listen
this isn't about you
let him go and tell me where your
passenger is i don't know where they
took him hell no
he's lying
look you you got two seconds to make up
your damn mind i'll decal those will
ride up here any minute now they're
headed west for the gas station but i
can't guarantee they're still there you
remember that you shut the [__] up
god damn it oh [__]
are you all right
just some scratches
you [__] morons did you get hit
hang on girl
i'll patch you up nothing
let's go
we couldn't retreat him
they were grouped so fast
started shooting rockets and [__]
i lost everyone
everyone
scorpion is he here
mitch
he's safe right damn i'm sorry
i didn't make it in time
no
are you sure
no he
scorpion the rest
i'm sorry we didn't get here sooner
they were good people
great people they didn't have to die
here i should have stopped him i tried
he wouldn't have listened to you either
never was much of a listener
stubborn bastard
i'm guessing since you were out here you
were out here for the av
the question is why
everything okay you need anything thanks
for saving my ass fee sorry about your
people
but i need to keep moving
why dive straight for the av
didn't notice the markings
we saw it was damaged we know this land
we knew where it would fall we had no
idea it was kang tao
i figured they might need help in the
worst case there'd be good salvage to be
had
couldn't have been more wrong
i need the man who was riding this av
pilot said they headed west yep
took him with him in our cars pilot was
telling the truth there's an old gas
station out there must be looking for a
way to call base so you're the ones who
hit him with that emp yeah we tried to
warn you but
couldn't connect
what's the plan now feet
go after him
stay with mitch i'll be fine
i'm going with you
i promised i would help
besides those bastards killed scorpion
i won't let that go don't argue with her
v no point
go i'll call my people we'll take care
of things here
we'll leave my ride here just in case
just watch the gun it likes to jam
we'll go by bike sounds solid
if they made it to the station they're
probably waiting on backup better hurry
but pan am what you're coming back for
her right i promise
let's get going before they send a
rescue party
scorpion and the rest
look
i know how you feel
i mean it
i'll help you settle your score with
kang tao
i will destroy them v
every last one we're in this together
to the bitter end you know what b
you're all right
you help me with nash you help me with
mitch
to my mind i owe you a favor
your helmet
i will find him ah so that's what this
is
just paying your debts
no
nomads always oh so i'm one of yours now
sounds good
let's delta to that station hope you
know a
shortcut get ready
the bikes are fine
hop on
me that well
probably better than i know
myself in the city we would get
ourselves an army
then we'd stock up in the road
cradle lake
that was his victory
bird is beautiful there
and then ryan deemer's car thrust into
the bottom
what
that corporate stole some sort of
prototype i think was militant
you don't remember
anyway chase the guy through three
states only to fish his body up out of
the lake
kill themselves
i think they hit him with a virus
anyway
lost control probably suffocated before
you drowned
that is [__] up
you stopped thinking about all that sad
[__] for a moment right
[Music]
they're on their last legs
carefully
christ be careful
jeez are you trying to make news
they will regret this
[Music]
you